bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vais vous
parler du futur des transports donc
mettez votre cerveau dans le futur mais
tout d'abord faisons un petit saut dans
le passé alors le transport au canada
c'est quoi eh bien sans 1849 que le
regretté act a permis d'étendre toutes
les lignes de chemin de fer au canada de
l'ouest à l'est est ce qui a permis
aujourd'hui d'avoir un réseau ultra
connectés sur tout le pays pendant les
années 1800 le train était le mode de
transport numéro un au canada
c'est bon c'est plus trop le coeur
j'habite à toronto maintenant et pour
venir à montréal parce que j'ai souvent
mourir
ça prouve pas mal de temps soit peu près
cinq heures qu'on prenne le train
loto où l'avion ça prend quand même
beaucoup trop de temps et ça c'est
principalement à cause de la politique
qui a été instruite au canada pour la
prédominance des transports routiers
c'est à dire que depuis les années 50 il
beaucoup d'investissements dans les
autoroutes qui a permis d'étendre un
réseau autoroutier grandiose au canada
et aux etats unis également
cependant les réseaux de transports
interurbains ont été totalement déchiré
par cet ultra investissements dans les
transports routiers et maintenant le
canada est le seul pays du g8 à ne pas
avoir de trains à grande vitesse
j'ai pas si vous avez appris le trait au
canada s'est passé quelque chose
donc c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui j'ai
envie de vous faire rêver un petit peu
imaginez que vous pouvez connecter
montréal à toronto en 40 minutes sans
aucune empreinte carbone et c'est
possible aujourd'hui avec la technologie
que l'on développe aujourd'hui à
transpole et c'est donc pas je vais vous
parler aujourd'hui
mutine avoir encore un petit peu
d'histoire parce que j'aime beaucoup
l'histoire qu'est ce que c'est que la
technologie adobe max qu'est ce qui nous
dit eh bien la technologie appelée hop
ça vient d'un processus relativement
simple quand on marche quand on prend le
vélo quand on prend notre auto ont fait
face à l'eire quand vous marchez à
montréal et qui a une grosse brosse
devant vous avez du mal à marcher
vous prenez loto vous accélérez parce
qu'à trop de vent bah c'est un petit peu
le problème tient dans les transports
aujourd'hui est le problème principal
des transports à grande vitesse
aujourd'hui c'est que plus on va aller
vite plus on vend on a besoin d'énergie
pour que ça aille plus vite et le
rendement qu'on a au fur et à mesure
qu'on augmente la vitesse est vraiment
mauvais donc l'air est un problème
mais ça ne vient pas seulement que l'air
est aussi le frottement aujourd'hui pour
se déplace on utilise l'art ou quelque
chose qui est super vieux on a
l'habitude d'utiliser les roues partout
pour le vélo pour la voiture
cependant la roue qu'est ce que ça fait
ça fait une friction une fraction sur le
sol une faction sur le support et cette
friction aller instable ça génère des
coûts ça génère de la 20 ans et ça
permet pas aujourd'hui au train grande
vitesse d'aller à plus de 400 kilomètres
à une vitesse opérationnel parce que ça
vivre trop parce que c'est trop cher à
entretenir parce que c'est pas efficace
dont claire c'est un problème et les
frais libration c'est un problème aucun
problème on va les enlever
non est ce un petit peu ça l'idée du
règlement général
ça a commencé en 1914 par brice weinberg
un chercheur et cette cité a été
renforcée par global gold qui est le
père actuelle actuelle
le père des deux works est en général
donc toutes et toutes les fusées et
cette idée en fait et permis à des
trains d'aller très très vite dans son
environnement sous vide sans aucun air
et en l'évitant grâce à des moteurs
magnétique alors si vous avez rien
compris c'est pas grave je voudrais
expliquer alors comment ça marche le
vélo pour sa part à peu près à la base
d'une capsule une capuche c'est quoi
c'est comme un wagon de train par
exemple on peut s'asseoir on peut avoir
quarante personnes ou 15 tonnes de fret
dedans et ce wagon ce déplacement des
tubes encore une fois leers un problème
donc on va enlever la dans lequel on va
le pomper grâce à des pompes à vide et
on va faire léviter ses capsules là pour
permettre d'aller extrêmement vite
et quand je dis vite ça va à peu près à
1200 km à une vitesse maximale donc
c'est très très rapide
on va déjà se littérale en avion c'est
pas très dangereux cependant il faut que
ce soit fait de la bonne manière
cette infrastructure et les fêtes de
deux tubes en acier de 4 mètres de
diamètre chaque 1 pour aller en phase 1
pour aller à reculons et 7 et sera
structuré peut être soit élevé soit sous
la terre soit sur la terre ça permet
bien
de jouer avec le paysage bon au canada
il n'a pas trop besoin parce que c'est
relativement plein mais ça aide
de plus on peut également mettre des
panneaux solaires sur l'infrastructure
pour réduire l'empreinte carbone
donc on va puiser l'énergie électrique
depuis la grille local est réinjecté
l'énergie que l'on produit avec les
panneaux solaires dans la vie locale
c'est très bien par exemple sur madame
l'implémenter au moyen orient par
exemple
donc on est dans une capsule
on a dû vie autour de nous c'est
effrayant on a eu peur qu'un bon alors
comment on fait alors la beauté de ce
mode de transport c'est que finalement
on sait déjà comment le faire on sait
déjà comment le construire les capuches
est très similaire finalement un avion
sans ailes
c'est très similaire à entrer dans un
train s'asseoir profiter et
d'environnement tout est pressurisé
et finalement on peut juste s'asseoir
avoir du fun pendant notre voyage
et puis sortir et allen destination et à
transporte chez nous à notre compagnie
on essaie vraiment de construire une
capsule qui respectent ni zain qui
puisse nous permettre d'aller à bon port
sans avoir trop de force g sur notre
corps est trop d'inconvénients
finalement l'expérience ce sera très
similaire à prendre le métro à montréal
nous essayer un petit peu de pression et
vous arrivez à votre destination sans
aucun problème alors comment est ce que
cette infrastructure qui est
relativement complexe va s'intégrer à
nos villes actuelles et voilà que c'est
l'intermodalité
vous avez peut-être entendu du projet du
projet de raismes à montréal donc le
réseau express métropolitains qui en
train d'être construit actuellement et
ils veulent faire beaucoup de station
intermodale de connecter plusieurs modes
de transport entre eux et bien ça c'est
la clé de tout la clé c'est assurer le
premier kilomètre et le dernier
kilomètre couvent tous les modes de
transport donc imaginer temps après la
conférence
vous avez envie d'aller boire une bière
à toronto révèle vous prenez le métro
vous allez à la station intermodale et
puis quand lui et après vous êtes à
toronto vous aurez votre bière dans la
main c'est très bien que moi j'aimerais
c'est en tout cas
donc vous comprenez que l'intégration
c'est très important pour les villes et
on sait déjà comment le faire alors
quelle tête auront les stations que l'on
va construire et bien
les stations sera très similaire aux
stations de trains que l'on connaît un
peu plus correct c'est pas comme la gare
centrale de montréal c'est un peu tabou
j'avais peur quand j'étais dedans mais
ce sera une station val hâtivement
ouverte
la clé c'est d'avoir une station très
facile d'accès donc on prend nos
téléphones cellulaires rentrer dans la
station on scanne entre billets et on va
directement plateforme nous à
transmettre notre but est d'avoir un
pote une capsule contenant 40 personnes
qui arrivent toutes les minutes
prête à vous prendre et paf vous envoyer
à votre destination et ça c'est la clé
d'un système de transport qui soit
efficient et efficace donc la clé pour
ce mode de transport pour qui pour qu'il
fonctionne et qu'il fasse un vrai impact
sur la société c'est le temps est ce qu
on sait le temps c'est de l'argent
en économie on aime ça met de la valeur
monétaire sur le temps alors visualiser
maintenant notre corps et leur moral
tantôt on a deux ou trois modes de
transport favori
l'outrance nos transports terrestres
loto le train et le bus et transpole
alors maintenant ça m'a pris cinq heures
pour aller entre les deux villes et
c'est lent c'est vraiment lent avec
françois n'ont pas les 1200 km heure ce
qui est relativement rapide
mais quel est l'impact dans le fond
d'aller aussi vite pourquoi on irait
aussi vite c'est quoi le ccal but
eh bien on va regarder un petit exemple
ici aujourd'hui il ya vingt mille
véhicules par jour qui voyagent dans ce
corridor
vingt mille véhicules par jour alors si
chaque véhicule gagne 82 temps ça fait
que finalement on va gagner dix ans par
jour en gain de temps sous la dent que
la société a gagné dix ans par jour à
chaque fois et ça c'est pour un corridor
imaginé pour 10 15 20 imaginez un réseau
à l'échelle du canada entier
ah c'est beaucoup de temps et le temps
c'est important alors si on visualise
les deux villes d'un point de vue
géographique vous qu'est ce que vous
connaissez de toronto
qu'est ce que vous connaissez de
vancouver qu'est ce que vous nous
connaissez de deux cargos a pas grand
chose et puis les torontois finalement
ils connaissent pas vraiment montréal
s'est pas seulement une distance
physique c'est une distance culturelle
pas la même langue
c'est pas la même façon de parler une
distance économique par les mêmes
entreprises pas les mêmes manières de
faire
donc réduire ses 10 ans et mettre les
deux villes côte à côte
ça aurait vraiment un impact hyper
profond sur le tissu économique et socio
économiques des deux villes et ça aurait
trois impacts majeurs
le premier c'est le volume de personnes
qui vont prendre ce mode de transport et
le volume de transport qui va être fait
dans le corridor le fait qu'il n'y ait
pas assez de densité de population dans
le corridor montréal ottawa et toronto
c'est un mythe c'est pas vrai ce
quelqu'un dise à ces lycéens vite il ya
au moins 10 millions de voyages qui
peuvent être faits chaque année dans ce
courrier dans là est tout simplement ça
peut être un gros gros gros boost à
l'économie locale
si un mode de transport comme cela est
intégré dans le fond morale pourrait
devenir une banlieue de toronto et on
devrait devenir une banlieue de montréal
imaginez les impacts économiques le
deuxième c'est la productivité avoir
deux villes côte à côte comme cela
permettra aux entreprises d'améliorer la
manière dont ils font du business mais
également d'avoir plus de personnes qui
vont travailler à toronto de personnes
qui vont travailler à montréal
imaginez montréal demain il a quarante
minutes de toronto il faut trouver une
job attentes racialement ou pour y aller
il faut le vivre à montréal et
travailler à tout ça va changer
absolument tout et le fait qu'il ait une
connexion aussi rapide va pas forcément
changé la perse la façon dont les gens
se déplacent mais la façon dont les gens
font du business également à façon et
android se localise on appelle ça le
clustering plus les entreprises ont une
des proportions à faire des économies
d'échelle entre elles pluie et vent se
localiser proche de chacune donc
finalement on aura un effet
multiplicateur sur l'économie locale
ça fait que plus on va investir dans un
secteur plus il y aura un effet
multiplicateur sur d'autres secteurs
puissent de dépenses des ménages plus de
ressources dépensées chez des
fournisseurs et ça ça pourrait étendre
l'économie de la région il véritablement
boosté l'économie du canada
mais l'économie ce n'est pas la seule
chose ce qu'ils sont a parlé des impacts
socio-économiques
on a parlé beaucoup de l'environnement
et je vous ai parlé de fait à l'heure
des panneaux solaires de l'impact
carbone net
on a également juin un boat est temps
que propos du hibou temps et le fait
qu'ils aient des nets et carbone négatif
mais c'est également possible avec ce
mode de transport
malheureusement au canada la performance
énergétique actuellement elle n'est pas
allée pas top
au canada 25 % de l'énergie fossile du
co2 les émissions de co2 sont émises par
les transports
c'est pas terrible et le canada est l'un
des plus gros pollueurs par capita au
monde
cependant au québec 80 pour 95 %
d'électricité produit par
l'hydroélectricité est une énergie
durable et renouvelable
donc là il ya un petit problème c'est
inadmissible pour maintenant que le
canada ne puisse pas électrifiée ces
transports correctement même s'il ya un
potentiel énorme
concernant l'électricité gratuite semi
gratuite et pas très fair et accessible
donc ça c'est un problème en mettant une
ligne entre toronto ottawa et montréal
on pourrait absorber 300 mille tonnes de
co2 par an 300 mi temps que c'est
l'équivalent de planter une grosse pour
est de la taille de l'île de montréal
ça fait beaucoup d'armes mais après
l'environnement ce n'est pas la seule
choisi aussi la sécurité qui dit canada
d'hiver et en hiver qu'est ce qu'on voit
mois les accidents sur l'autoroute on
voit des camions s'empiler voir des
voitures sans fil on a des gens mourir
et ça c'est pas vraiment ce qu'on veut
pour les transports dans le pays métro
ligne entre toronto moral ces soirées
davis est sauvé à peu près 300 accidents
par an et non seulement va sauver des
accidents mais également vu que le mode
de transport et dans un tube
ab la neige peut pas aller dans le tube
donc ça va permettre de sauver des vies
aussi durant les opérations du mode de
transport alors les applications et vous
bien au delà de ça répond plus dans un
cadre social en investissant plus dans
les transports durables propre et
efficace
on va changer la manière dans laquelle
les gens se déplacent et j'envoie
prendre plus le vélo
ils ont pu ce point des transports
publics est connecté avec les modes de
transport intermodal qui sont entre les
différentes villes et dans le fond on
aura un changement des comportements de
chacun cependant très honnêtement le
canada a développé une telle culture de
la voiture forcé par la politique
d'investissements publics dans le temps
que ça va être très difficile de changer
les mentalités et non seulement ça
difficile à changer les mentalités muos
au change et les la manière dont les
investissements sont faits
bien qu'il y ait de l'amélioration
actuellement donc c'est pour ça que dans
le but de changer ce qui se passe
actuellement il est très important que
chacun d'entre nous est un impact chacun
d'entre nous prenne des décisions et
essaye de changer la manière dont on
entre donc au voyage et de développer
l'innovation et les transports de 4,3
manière dont on peut faire ça la
première si vous conduisez une voiture
actuellement et si vous avez accès au
métro des bus vendez votre voiture vous
n'avez pas besoin vous l'a loué la fin
de semaine
si vous voulez aller au parc au chalet
ce problème
prenez le métro encourager le transport
public
deuxièmement si vous voulez commencer
les entreprises si vous voulez commencer
quelque chose dans le domaine de
l'infrastructure ou les transports
durables ou de l'innovation ou n'importe
quoi faites-le encourager le cas
économique pour mobilité durable ont
corrigé le cas économique pour le
développement durable c'est l'économie
c'est le marché qui va dicter le succès
de ce genre de mode de transport et puis
finalement si vous voyez rien faire du
tout puis vous voulez pas le faire et
bien parlez-en parlé du besoin qu'on a
actuellement d'avoir de meilleurs modes
de transport parler de l'impact
économique que ça ira et parlé également
de fait que lévis seront meilleurs
finalement et si vous dites que maxime
c'est parce qu'il connaît rien on pourra
pas faire ça pas chacun d'entre nous ça
c'est pas vrai je vous donne un exemple
j'ai vécu au danemark pendant un an
magnifique pays et il se trouve qu'à
copenhague la capitale du danemark
tout le monde prend le vélo parce que le
vélo c'est le mode de transport numéro 1
de marc bisson il ya quelques années
c'était pas vraiment ça il ya quelques
années au danemark
finalement moins de 10% de la population
comprenait le vélo pour aller au travail
et puis beaucoup de voitures cela
restait pas vraiment attractifs comme
mode de transport
mais les gens voulaient vraiment avoir
un mode de transport plus durables et
voulait se déplacer de maux d'une
manière plus efficace
donc est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont tous
pris le vélo ils ont tous décidé d'aller
aux travailleurs vo ensemble et chaque
fois que quelqu'un allait se faire taper
par une voiture en prenant le vélo il
allait prendre la peinture est dessinée
l'empreinte de la personne morte sur la
route
ça c'est drastique mais ça a marché
aujourd'hui maintenant 50% de la
population de copenhague prend le vélo
pour aller au travail et c'est le réseau
numéro un mondial des pistes cyclables
et pour l'avoir pris je pourrais
garantir c'est vraiment bien
donc ça montre que vous pouvez avoir un
impact tous ensemble et l'importance et
les forces sociales
si vous êtes capables tous deux parlent
et mobilité durables et de vous engager
économiquement et socialement on pourra
accéder à des meilleurs transports merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]